we have claimed that normal random
variables are very important and
therefore we would like to be able to
calculate probabilities associated with
them for example given a normal random
variable what is the probability that it
takes a value less than 5 unfortunately
there are no closed-form expressions
that can help us with this in particular
the CDF the cumulative distribution
function of normal random variables is
not given in closed form but fortunately
we do have tables for the standard
normal random variable these tables
which take the form shown here give us
the following information if we have a
normal random variable which is a
standard normal they tell us the values
of the cumulative distribution function
for different values of little Y in
terms of a picture if this is the PDF of
a standard normal and I give you a value
little Y I'm interested in the
corresponding value of the CDF which is
the area under the curve
well that value the area under this
curve is exactly what this table is
giving to us and there's a shorthand
notation for referring to the CDF of the
standard normal which is just Phi of Y
let us see how we use this table suppose
were interested in
Phi of 0 which is the probability that
our standard normal takes a value less
than or equal to 0 well by symmetry
since the PDF is symmetric around 0 we
know that this probability should be 0.5
let's see what the table tells us well 0
corresponds to this entry which is
indeed point 5 let us look up the
probability that our standard normal
takes a value less than let's say 1
point 16 how do we find this information
one is here and one point 1 is here
one point one and then we have a six in
the next decimal place which leads us to
this entry and so this value is zero
point eight seven seven zero similarly
we can calculate the probability that
the normal is less than two point nine
how do we look up this information two
point nine is here we do not have
another decimal digit so we're looking
at this column and we obtained this
value which is zero point nine nine
eight one and by looking at this number
we can actually tell that a standard
normal random variable has extremely low
probability of being bigger than two
point nine now notice that the table
specifies Phi of Y for y being
non-negative what if we wish to
calculate the value for example of Phi
of minus two in terms of a picture this
is a standard normal here is minus two
and we wish to calculate this
probability there's nothing in the table
that gives us this probability directly
but we can argue as follows the normal
PDF is symmetric so if we look at two
then this probability here which is Phi
of minus 2 is the same as that
probability here of that tail what is
the probability of that tail it's one
which is the overall area under the
curve minus the area under the curve
when you go up to the value of two so
this quantity is going to be the same as
Phi of minus two and this one we can now
get from the tables it's 1 minus let us
see 2 is here it's 1 minus 0.9 7
and to the standard normal table gives
us probabilities associated with the
standard normal random variable what if
we're dealing with a normal random
variable that has a mean and the
variance that are different from those
of the standard normal what can we do
well there's a general trick that you
can do to a random variable which is the
following let us define a new random
variable Y in this fashion Y measures
how far away is X from the mean value
but because we divide by Sigma the
standard deviation it measures this
distance in standard deviations so if y
is equal to 3 it means that X is three
standard deviations away from the mean
in general Y measures how many
deviations away from the mean argue what
properties does this random variable
have the expected value of y is going to
be equal to 0 because we have X and
we're subtracting the mean of X so the
expected value of this term is equal to
0 how about the variance of Y whenever
we multiply a random variable by a
constant the variance gets multiplied by
the square of that constant so we get
this expression but the variance of X is
Sigma squared so this is equal to 1 so
starting from X we have obtained a
closely related random variable Y that
has the property that it has 0 mean and
unit variance if it also happens that X
is a normal random variable then Y is
going to be a standard normal random
variable so we have managed to relate X
to a standard normal random variable and
perhaps you can rewrite this expression
in this form x equals to MU plus Sigma Y
where Y is now a standard normal so
instead of doing calculations having to
do with egg
we can try to calculate in terms of y
and for y we do have available tables
let us look at an example of how this is
done the way to calculate probabilities
associated with general normal random
variables is to take the event whose
probability we want to calculate it and
express it in terms of standard normal
random variables and then use the
standard normal tables let us see how
this is done in terms of an example
suppose that X is normal with mean 6 and
variance 4 so that the standard
deviation Sigma is equal to 2 and
suppose that we want to calculate the
probability that X lies between 2 & 8
here's how we can proceed this event is
the same as the event that X minus 6
takes a value between 2 minus 6 and 8
minus 6 this event is the same as the
original event we were interested in we
can also divide both sides of this
inequality by the standard deviation and
the event of interest has now been
expressed in this form but at this point
we recognize that this is of the form X
minus mu over Sigma so this random
variable here is a standard normal
random variable so the probability that
X lies between 2 & 8 is the same as the
probability that the standard normal
random variable call it Y falls between
this number is minus 4 divided by 2
that's minus 2 y less than 1 and now we
can use the standard normal tables to
calculate this probability we have here
1 and here we have minus
and we want to find the probability that
our standard normal falls inside this
range this is the probability that it is
less than one but we need to subtract
the probability of that tail so that
we're left just with this intermediate
area so this is the probability that Y
is less than one minus the probability
that Y is less than minus two and
finally as we discussed earlier the
probability that Y is less than minus 2
this is 1 minus the probability that Y
is less than or equal to 2 and now we
can go to the normal tables identify the
values that were interested in the
probability that Y is less than 1 the
probability that Y is less than 2 and
plug this in and this gives us the
desired probability again the key step
is to take the event of interest and by
subtracting the mean and dividing by the
standard deviation express that same
event in an equivalent form but which
now involves a standard normal random
variable and then finally use the
standard normal tables